Can I have you that fun?
He'll blow up a paper view.
Yeah,
for sure.
So cause you still look great.
Phenomenal.
He's ends in La Right now.
Training with Freddy and they said he's real thin to looking at a 55 fight.
Wow.
And even though even though it could be,
does stand a lot and,
and play on his feet a lot,
his,
his main objective is to take a motherfucker down.
That's the main,
that's number one.
Don't fuck around and throw some strikes.
Why?
Why are they still talking about a Floyd Mayweather fight?
It's embarrassing.
I don't know what the fuck they're doing is just talking about,
I know he goes,
I have three fights left.
If it's up to me,
it's Tony Gsp,
GSP and fully man Floyd Mayweather.
When I hear that I want to throw up.
But what do you,
they just want some money and get the fuck out.
Do you think he thinks he can beat him cause he's such a savage.
Mike can't beat him.
Like they don't think Floyd can knock him out while we're in for a rude
awakening.
Well he certainly bad.
Are you?
I mean,
maybe he lasts all 12,
but they get battered to fuck up will be awful.
But he'll be okay.
You know what's going to get paid if that's what you wanna do you get paid?
Do I?
I'd much rather see him fighting GSP.
Yeah,
me too.
But I don't think,
um,
I don't think it's,
I mean it's a terrible move for him to fight.
Floyd Floyd would just look,
Floyd is the best box or maybe of our era maybe of all time.
He's,
he's undefeated.
Here's the problem.
The UFC,
let Connor do that once and now he's Kinda,
we can barely get them to fight is worth a hundred.
You galean dollars and they're like,
do please fight.
He's like,
Nah,
I make so much money,
whiskey and this.
Yeah,
I'll fight when I'm ready.
They're not gonna let that ever,
you're never going to see that again.
I don't think you ever,
you see that crazy.
They made an app now that now,
now that,
uh,
the Fertittas don't own the UFC and now like this corporation owns it.
Now everyone is not one is at the helm.
But what are you saying?
I'm saying that Connor has so much leverage now where it's not a good thing,
so you think you're going to make someone a giant star who could be a giant star
because they're worried that person's going to have leverage.
No,
they'll make them a giant star in the UFC.
They're not going to let him jump over and do a co-promotion with Floyd
Mayweather.
Again,
listen to doing it.
Who else would they do it with theirs?
That's the better question.
Here's the thing.
If they had another Connor,
they do it the same way.
It's a way to make money.
It's a smart way to make money.
It was a fun fight.
We watched it.
We got to seat.
You can sit education.
It's an education for people that appreciate martial arts because you really got
to understand what a world class top of the food chain,
maybe the best of all time boxer does to an MMA fighter and you think we're
going to pay for it.
The general audience,
he keeps paying for that.
I'm not what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is is it was getting us up.
It was good for the,
it was good for the sport and if someone comes along that's different.
Someone comes along,
it's not Floyd did someone else and the same situation arises again and this is
another opportunity to make a shitload of money.
They're going to do it again.
How many tenants do you see in a load?
Floyd's 40 years old.
He probably doesn't want to do it that many more times.
The only thing that would fuck Floyd up is it.
His extravagant isn't a bad look for MMA too.
So let's say Floyd's 27 at this point and he's one of the greatest and we go,
here's Connor smokes him,
here's Khabib's smoked him here.
Style bench smokes it.
At what point is UFC like this a bad look man,
our guys can fucking torched with.
Depends on whether or not it's obvious that they had no chance.
Like with Connor,
the,
the interesting thing is like he landed a couple of shots get up and you go,
okay,
if this guy could take this guy down or even just kick his legs,
if car I could just kick his legs,
it would be a wash.
And it's interesting to watch someone even fail against someone who's way better
at their sport.
The real question is,
you're ever,
are you ever going to see a worldclass boxer by Tom?
We saw James,
Tony,
he had been like really late in the game when Vince Phillips Fought Masato and k
one he was way late in the game.
They were on their way out looking for money.
Right?
Afterthoughts,
right after thoughts for the most part,
for the most part.
Do you ever think you're going to see like a,
uh,
a Crawford step into MMA Aloma Chanko step in MMA in their prime?
I don't think so.
Why would you get making so much money?
I know they need to make it sell cause if they're at that level,
they're making so much money and you,
why would you risk going to the UFC?
Think about in 50 years how awesome that put a poster is going to be at Conor
and Floyd fucking I love frame that.
She loves going to be 90 and it's going to be framed and I have that shit.
I have the official one,
Joe Louis Max Schmeling Dolly and Gnocchi.
Yeah.
Oh,
you're in your living room.
See,
I'm all good on that.
I saw that.
It was a great spectacle.
I love being part of watching.
I'm glad killed the paper views.
I'm out,
man.
If someone else does it,
it's not,
it's fun.
I don't think talking about,
so if someone else comes along,
so you're telling me you same person would and Connor,
I'm saying it could be even Floyd,
you'd be like,
well you're talking to degenerate.
I watch it.
I watch women fuck in their underwear.
Beetle kill you like me to,
I'm saying the mass is,
I don't think,
God don't worry about the mat.
I don't think.
I don't think you're right.
Well that's what the UFC where think many more.
If it could be stepped in and tried to fight Floyd right now.
Right now,
if they set it up in two months,
I guarantee you it would sell at least a million pages about an encounter.
You would want to say you think it does?
No,
I don't think that's close to a million.
I said it does.
1 million could fight the fucking Jamie from,
do you think you would do a million pay per views or more or more something
like,
well,
here's the thing,
you'd be proud to a million.
It's Floyd.
He doesn't miss when,
who was,
um,
who was a Floyd's last fall?
Was it Pacquiao and then Tim Bradley,
if I pack out then Tim Bradley and I'm retired.
Right.
And the pack,
y'all got the giant,
the most paper view numbers ever.
But then Tim Bradley,
if I'm correct,
only got a few hundred thousand,
like 300,000 out of there.
Wasn't that right?
Yeah,
that's right.
So then he fights Connor and he gets like 2 million,
whatever the fuck it was her giant paper.
You say Andre Berto.
Rj Birds.
That's right.
So he fought.
My apologies.
Tim Bradley.
So then he fights Andre Berto that only gets 350,000 or something like that.
Pay per view buys.
Then he flights.
Connor fights Connor,
and it's millions of pay per views.
If he fucked could be,
but it would still be better than fighting any of those other guys.
Agree.
100% Bradley.
Like if safe,
he had a fight with Bradley or save Nolan's tuna.
No,
that couldn't be that many pack elvish fully middle is probably,
you can get that again.
It's a big one.
That's a big one.
Especially bandy pack.
Hell now after we be Broner.
After he backed up that Australian dude look good.
He looked very Jeff [inaudible],
the Australian guy,
he lost his power TC and then
40 40 okay.
He's still good.